we got this it's good
you think you can hold them off
captain
it'll be my genuine pleasure
that is actor jeremy renner as the arrow
slinging hawkeye in the avengers the
actor known for playing a superhero on
the big screen is now taking his talents
to television and the mayor of kingstown
the explosive new drama takes place in a
fictional michigan town where the only
industry is the prison system he plays
mike mccluskey who along with his
brother mitch are fixers working to fix
the problems both inside and outside of
the prison system
look we had your kid in protection right
but he's got a big mouth and not much
common sense so what do you want he's in
a headset believe me that's the safest
place it can be your kid fractured that
guard's jaw
but when they throw the book at them
they don't want somebody 17 year old in
front of that judge
so he's fine for now but he's got
understanding you've got to understand
he's getting another five years on that
sentence and he's got to come to grips
with the fact jeremy winter joins us now
jeremy how you doing good morning
good morning how you doing
good good now your character mike he
becomes the mayor of kingstown now
that's the unofficial title what's his
official role in the town
uh ultimately he has a unique um
[Music]
relationship with everybody in the
prison the whole prison system and
the workings of it uh so essentially
he's like the grease for the whole
engine or the wheels that uh are the is
the business of incarceration
i think number one it's a great
character to play and you were great in
it and part of the relationship you have
is with the top drug dealer in town
they're friends but on the other hand at
any second they could also beat each
other so they'd kill each other and i
i'm curious if you could talk about the
dynamics of the different characters and
what you have to do
yeah i think uh that's what it makes the
show really really interesting and it's
it's um
it's still so much character based and
there's a lot of relationships that
you you you follow and you you find it
doesn't become like episodic television
because it really isn't it's like a 10
hour movie and it really is because of
all the the relationships that are the
reformed
and there's a lot of tension that
is in with in all these relationships um
even within the family um
because there's a lot of a lot of
history a lot of
level of depth and complexities and
a lot of lives are on the line and
it gets with the pendulum swing at any
given moment
so it makes it pretty exciting you're on
the road right now you're working you've
got this coming out you you've got
hawkeye uh coming out in serious form
later this year uh but you uh when you
go home you will go home to a uh to the
northern part of nevada as i understand
it you live in the country what are you
gonna do when you get back yeah first
thing you're going to do yep
i got to move some fire trucks off the
mountains before they get buried in snow
that's fire that's probably the first
thing i like you have like a lot of fire
yeah
you asked
wait
are you like the chief are you like the
volunteer fire chief in your town
yeah yeah it's it's moving into that
direction yeah i'm doing a lot of things
with um retired fire trucks and um and
and repurpose them and reimagining them
and
using them for different things and then
also donating to other communities that
don't have the resources and things like
that but i also have like a volunteer
fire department up on my property as
well because we live in a high you know
hot zone a lot a lot of fires and stuff
happen every year and um so
jeremy renner nice guy no doubt he is a
nice guy jeremy renner i like it
incredible in everything that you are
involved in and now i know i can
describe you in more ways than one great
actor yep family man yep hawkeye you are
now the mayor and of course volunteer
firefighter jeremy renner thank you so
much for joining us you can watch the
mayor of kingstown premiering sunday on
viacom cbs streaming platform paramount
plus